[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on The  Bachelor we had a bloodbath that ended  in tears I just wanted to be honest and  I want to be real with you guys next  tears yes he sent home not one not two  but six women on Monday night's episode  including both whitney and danielle from  his two-on-one date yeah normally you  keep one of the ladies from a two-on-one  but nope Nick sent Danielle who many had  considered a front-runner home after  that he went to speak to the other women  about what had went down I just wanted  to be honest and I want to be real with  you guys it was quite a dramatic episode  what do you guys think of the fact that  Nick sent Danielle el home let me know  on twitter i'm at lauren zima  [Music]  you